now what about your search for happiness
i know you're constantly looking for
that one thing that's going to make you
happy
what is it what are you doing to try and
find happiness well i'm so
i'm so generally so happy that i have to
mute it because people get really tired
of you
when you know when you're successful and
you're happy and stuff like that it's
just like
and i got to tell you conan i'm not only
happy but i'm filthy rich
[Laughter]
okay okay it's good to know
and i like to keep that on the down low
you like to keep that quiet that quiet
yeah you got to be careful
right you got to be careful but yeah i'm
generally pretty happy yeah i i uh
i i'm into expanded consciousness like
right now even sitting here
i am the audience right you oh you think
you are the audience is that what
expanded consciousness is totally
you think that you are the your soul
doesn't stop at the edge of your skin
conan
it goes out further and you can expand
and you can expand and you're not only
people but you're things as well
you're everything and everyone and so no
one can ever take anything away from me
because i am everything
oh what's that what's that had an itch
you had an ah
i couldn't you are me you could be a
little dry you are a little dry back
there yeah it should moisturize more
let me adjust hey hey hey hey yeah
that was not bad uh enjoyed that
it is the holidays we wish you the the
best of the holiday season uh
anything you mean you mean you wish me a
merry christmas is that what you're
trying to say
can't legally say it no no
because uh because i wish you a merry
christmas
in fact i'll go step one step further
and wish you a christy christy good time
a crazy good time i don't hear that
phrase enough
yeah because that's really what it's
about isn't it the birth of the baby
jesus yeah
you know what i'm going to do i'm going
to go up to canada into a small
cabin in the woods where there's no
lawyers and i'm going to have a mass
in the honor of christ that's what i'm
going to do
well i'm going gonna sue you now and you
can just you can
sit here and celebrate the the the uh
separation of church and state
there's some great music that goes with
that there's some great separation of
church and state
jingles there's some nice ones talk
about that do you get when you get in
the spirit do you like to sing
i love the carols you love the carols i
love the carols but they
they make me really emotional i mean
they do they really they touch me and
they go way back i'm going way back it
reminds me of
really beautiful joyful things and and
it's uh
so i mean i like to sing them you want
to sing one little just us a little
carol right now
[Applause]
okay that what this is for my natchez is
there
i don't know but i just left that there
yeah someone left it
okay uh can you give me a little uh
silent night
just this is gonna be hard
[Music]
oh
oh man all right all right it's
oh i'm sorry all right well this is wait
wait wait wait wait wait
wait it's too painful let me try it let
me try it one more time okay can i try
one more sure yeah
okay just give me one more time take it
easy
[Music]
i'm sorry all right that's true you
don't have to you don't have to sing it
it's okay i didn't want to upset you
that's all right you don't have to my
parents were drunk at christmas
okay i'm sorry i'm i'm so sorry
jim i apologize is there anything we can
do to make it oh man oh man
oh i gotta i gotta get through this
because i'm a professional mm-hmm
[Laughter]
maybe if i maybe if i sang the old carol
but you like did it with a modern twist
whatever that night
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hollywood
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
silence
[Music]
[Applause]
language
[Music]
you